hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay making our
way down Oh yup think about the chatter
he's really whoa oh no
right off the bat starting with the semi
in the Hey
no Connor Oh screw you I don't care I
don't care I don't care best strategy
just run straight through Oh
ha ha ya got me cat
no oh you hit me anyway but I don't care
I don't care don't care don't care
no go away
etk of hell wha
CJ on him wha wha
ms of course I miss I'm terrible
okay
that one behind me
all big guy
it wouldn't be a party without you my
friend
it's a body why not no knob it not screw
it screw what the [ __ ] am i doing anyway
can't kill him I'll know the big skater
sing right there
whatevs bro it look like I care
what no holy crap
nope get away through you I saw you baby
no no no no no no no not gonna get me
not gonna get me good good good good
log next to anyone who may find this
transmission there are people even in
front of my own staff who say I'm a
monster the burn when I brought to this
station you say the marker is
manipulative that it influences my
decisions they don't understand what I
did I did this for this community for
our species guidance station with the
dead husk before I breathed life back
into it with government research grants
that research into unimaginable sources
of energy in a manufacturing techniques
and efficiency far beyond all previous
understanding is the only thing hope
that remain
for mankind it relied on destructive
planet cracking for far too long now we
can no longer sustain ourselves he need
the marker to survive
we fail in our effort to understand that
there is no
that yeah right there's no hope left
right now
again I thought this was gonna get me to
the end
mark ah get away seriously how much
longer oh shut up
oh shut up
there oh you got to be joking Oh
what it's what this is this is nowhere
ah
up here why was that door even open
Oh finally ah Ginga marker now how the
heck hi [ __ ] you buddy
Oh God ah you son of a [ __ ] I'm going
to murder you so hard smash that eben I
won't let you throw this away on your
side of it I don't get
kill him yes murder him yes
ah yeah satisfaction ha ha yeah
turn of year Jeff yes yes yeah no no I
don't trust you lady
No Thank You Isaac
no oh no time today oh boy
oh that I'm going into my own head you
need to be reborn the makers must be
oh I knew it
yes [ __ ] you did it burn
Wow No
yellow chewed the yellow shoot the
yellow is a good gun cuff Oh burning
apparently we're okay little guys little
guys little guys [ __ ] you [ __ ] you all
[ __ ] you all
ah supposed to work well this is
supposed to work well ah supposed to
work really well on you guys and it's
not it doesn't seem to be
ah goddamn it gonna be kidding me whoa
hello
which yeah
rip it apart reload ah dammit they're
coming after me ah what what what
I wasn't even law Nell nice ah ah
here goes my hat I really seem to have
lost my head yeah well that was my bad I
got caught up with should have been
hanging there to my laugh don't burn her
not that actually actually that's not a
good that's not
c'mere [ __ ] man Oh Holmes one day
[ __ ] all around me whoa hello shut up
burn burn all of you this hatchet
[ __ ] you there go I get away get away
get away get away I should have brought
more help
ah yeah
burn up you [ __ ] okay let me reload
this [ __ ] but you all would have been
gone where's
ah god damn it you killing me
ah
how is that fair she popped right in
front of me [ __ ] uh-uh-uh
you [ __ ] okay I know just how to greet
you just one one does the trick huh one
does the trick
what the hell one does good trick
dammit dammit dammit get away listen get
away get away oh you gotta be kidding me
burn you [ __ ] no stasis ah you gotta
be [ __ ] me what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
just get over with it
I wish I wish I had the pulse right [ __ ]
all I would not be dying nearly as much
as I happened if I had the [ __ ] pulse
right
this [ __ ] would be simple I'd only
need a one gun
[ __ ]
shut up Wow freaky freaky lady get it I
can run around the perimeter and box
them into a big line that I can
Center
back away
[ __ ] she's gone then I just run around
gather them up a big chain without dying
[ __ ] what the hell
what the [ __ ] use a [ __ ] health kit
I'm out you're [ __ ] me I'm out I'm
out of hell oxy one there there's one
there let me get it get away get away
get away you [ __ ] oh damn it
[ __ ] hell how could I go into this
with no help seriously I had help
he just tried lobbing these things
doing jack
[ __ ]
ha [ __ ]
I can't deal with
yes
there we go happen again
shut up oh damn damn it and I'm out I
have like [ __ ] help that's the reason
why
but in reality I have [ __ ] about see one
over there they're good everything about
you
what the hell they're more
so I helped it on the ground
it's good
how much help Christmas they have oh you
all know I'm so bummed because I'm out
of plasma energy line gun
[ __ ] hell go away go away [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
Oh another health get give me that ah
goddamn it [ __ ] it [ __ ] this ah goddamn
it goddamn it goddamn it
there we go ah why are you still here
[ __ ] [ __ ] mind gun do it please oh go
boom so long
ah so boned up Oh [ __ ] hell
I have known
about more help
[ __ ] [ __ ]
well I only got time for one more try
you
there are no [ __ ] hell oh my god are
you Amy
I just where to God this flavor is not
job
okay seriously that's I I failed I
[ __ ] failed it's just [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] alright anyway that's all the
time I got for this episode sorry about
failing
goddamnit I just didn't have the I
didn't have [ __ ] medkits
I had zero just look at wonder I'm
curious how many did I actually have
two little itty bitty small med kits
that's what I had [ __ ] hell anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode oh I'm going to go back to a
save that I had before and I'm just
gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] buy up enough to
get to the end of the game because this
boss fight is nothing like the last boss
fight this boss fight is not fun but
this isn't even a boss fight but
whatever whatever that's just gonna have
to wait until the next episode so thank
you everyone so much for watching and
bearing with me and now we'll see you in
the next part bye-bye